do you know what talking thrones is a
YouTube channel just waiting for people
to come along and watch it like a
Valyrian steel sword sharp and unfilled
with videos ready to be shared talking
thrones isn't a bit talking Thrones the
ladder then you try to top it fail never
get to try again theories and
predictions break them some are given
the chance to watch they refuse the
killing devoured gas or other channels
the talking throws is all there is
what's up ladies and gentlemen how's
everybody doing today in this video I
want to talk about another potential
wedding slash Alliance we could see take
place during Game of Thrones Season
eight there's all season there has been
many many videos about potential
marriages that we could see any upcoming
seasons so I figured I throw my hat in
the ring and talk about a few that I
wouldn't mind seeing myself if you saw
one of my previous videos then you know
I talked about the chances of Oriya and
Gentry getting together but in this
video I want to talk about an old flame
being reignited smokescreen and I
actually talked about this briefly in
her collab video we did together so now
I want to take the time and discuss it a
little bit more which is the
relationship between Sansa Stark and
Tyrion Lannister the wolf and the lion
now that Ramsay Bolton is dead and Songz
is back with her family there is a
chance that we could see her tie the
knot once more or we tie the knot I
should say but I must warn you there
will be some spoilers in his video so in
case you didn't see the spoilers in the
title I want to give you a fair warning
now I won't really discuss any
foreshadowing or book clues in this
video basically I'm just going to base
this off of both of the characters
availability and eligibility in the show
and how likely it is that this could
happen but initially you may be thinking
why would songs I want to marry Tyrion
she wanted nothing to do with him in the
first place the NIE Tyrion was supposed
to consummate the marriage
Tyrion had told so-and-so that he would
not do it until she wanted him to which
songs are then replied what if I never
want you to
at the time zones it was still holding
on to this dream of living a fairytale
life of marrying a king or highlord and
having little princes and princesses
running around but that dream soon faded
away
Joffrey showed songs or just how cruel
this world could be but she still had
hope of one day marrying ser Loras
instead yes the dashing knight of
flowers but that dream was also
shattered when she was forced into
marrying the IMP Tyrion Lannister but if
things couldn't get any worse
after Joffrey's death she was rushed out
of King's Landing and into the hands of
one of the most dangerous men in
Westeros Ramsay Bolton who later married
songs and held her captive which
basically gave him free rein to beat and
rape her whenever he pleased and there
was nothing she could really do about it
at the time but thankfully not only did
she escape but she also played a role in
defeating Ramsay to his own hounds and
trust me not a single tear was shed for
that evil prick but I say all that to
say this songs us perspective on men and
marriage has changed by now that dream
of living a fairy tale
is and should be dead but this doesn't
mean she's never going to marry again
the Great War is coming and alliances
are going to be needed more importantly
armies are going to be needed to win
this war against the others and what do
we know about marriages and Game of
Thrones it's a great way to make
alliances or end up dead depending on
what color the wedding is
like wedding but Daenerys said it
herself way before she left Marines she
basically said this very same thing to
Daario and what do we know about John he
needs men and John knows better than
anyone just how great the threat beyond
the wall is and John's first major order
of business as king is going to be to
make some new alliances and we know this
from leaked photos that John is going to
leave Winterfell pretty early during
season seven he's going to head down
south to Dragonstone in order to meet
with Daenerys and Tyrion and this is
going to be one of the most important
meetings of John's life he's going to
need to get their help in order to win
this war now most people think we could
see a marriage between John and Daenerys
but let's not forget that the marriage
between Sons and Tyrion could be just as
important Damaris is going to want the
north on her side and who is one of her
most trusted advisors at this point
demand that she just named hand of the
Queen Tyrion mother freaking Lannister
so I don't think it's too crazy to think
that these two could end up together
once again if Jonathan Aerys do not end
up together let's say if they find out
that they are related and that makes
them decide not to or let's just say if
one of them dies either way this could
be a way to form their strong alliance
between the north and the south
not to mention how great would it be to
see Cersei's reaction when she heard the
news
if Cersei would still be alive at this
point we know that Cersei hates Tyrion
in Sansa so can you imagine a look on
her face if she found out that they got
back together and had the biggest army
behind them ready to strike her down I
would absolutely love that but let's
forget about this being a marriage for
an alliance for a minute and let's just
think about how good Tyrion was to Sansa
Tyrion treated her like an absolute
gentleman Tyrion promised awnser that he
would never hurt her and he never did
Tyrion treated Sansa and the Starks in
general with the utmost respect Tyrion
was actually one of the few people in
the South who was not pleased when he
found out about the red wedding and all
those songs it definitely has some trust
issues now I'm sure she wouldn't forget
the way that Tyrion had treated her now
I'm going to save my end game theory for
Sansa for another video but I do expect
to see Tyrion as one of the final
remaining characters alive when this all
ends
I see Tyrion as being one of the key
figures left in the show that's going to
around for this dream of spring one of
the few characters left that can help
restore what was once destroyed but
could songs would be one of those
characters too could she be left with
Tyrion to help rebuild after the Great
War is over
Sansa might not be physically attracted
to Tyrion but after the experience she's
went through that may not be a priority
anymore knowing that Tyrion would treat
her well may Trump her risking another
abusive relationship with someone just
because of the way that they look I
think Tyrion and saans are getting back
together in the end is very possible and
let's be honest I wouldn't mind seeing
them back together myself
if I had to pick anyone to marry sons at
this point it would be Tyrion I
definitely do not want to see Songza and
Jon get together but let's look at it
this way also Jon and Tyrion didn't get
along at first but they soon came to
respect each other after their time
spent together at the wall now I know it
wasn't the exact same scenario as the
book but since we're not talking about
the book I have to go off of what we've
seen on the screen and when Tyrion left
the wall jon said he was sad to see him
go they were no longer trading insults
at this point but they actually
addressed each other by their
respectable titles so I expect to see
their relationship grow even stronger
when they do meet again and actually
start working with one another when it
comes to game planning against the
others so it doesn't hurt that Jon
already likes Tyrion this could play a
factor into Tyrion and Sansa linking up
again Sons of Stark is still a valuable
bride in so many ways so if she does get
married again who do you see her getting
with or who do you want to see her get
with my money would be on Tyrion in the
end but there could still be a chance
that she marries sweet Robin still but I
don't see him surviving until the end so
if that would happen it would be another
short-lived engagement for her but
there's someone I want to shout out
before I go which is gray area if you
haven't watched anything on her channel
yet then you are really missing out she
has some great fairies with some more
great ones on the way me and her we're
actually talking about Tyrion and Sansa
and gray area has this really cool
theory about something that may happen
between these two characters now I'm not
going to spoil her idea here but let's
just say if it does come true it would
not only be poetic as she put it but
also heartbreaking at the same time but
it was such an interesting idea and I
had to let you know all about it because
it may be her next video
so definitely go check out our channel
that way you can watch it when she does
release it you're not going to be
disappointed trust me
but songs as much older now an
experienced so I don't think Tyrion
would be opposed to this he's always
been looking for love
so maybe what songs that he can find
that love but let me know what you think
though give me your opinion on s I also
want to shout out those of you that have
showed your support on patreon Jeanne
USMC Sir Thomas Indy racecar broadcast
cipher solar James Millar a dawn of Ice
and Fire
Kari marine C on defense squad aka Brit
and my bannermen cows [ __ ] chickens
thank you everyone
I'll see you down on a comment section
bye